through the government's ongoing  monitoring and testing program as of  today 660 9850 test for coronavirus have  now been carried out in the UK including  29,000 and 58 tests carried out  yesterday one hundred and fifty two  thousand eight hundred and forty people  have tested positive and that's an  increase of four thousand four hundred  and sixty three cases since yesterday  fifteen thousand nine hundred and fifty  three people are currently in hospital  with the corona virus in the UK down  from 16 thousand four hundred and eleven  on the 25th of April and sadly of those  hospitalized with the virus 20 thousand  seven hundred and thirty-two have now  died and that is an increase to four  hundred and thirteen fatalities since  yesterday and we express our deepest  condolences to the families and friends  of these victims